we've got this story this morning it's
incredible dramatic accounts overnight
from Americans who survived a plane
crash in Mexico and they're giving new
insight into why it may have gone down
cell phone video from inside the Aero
Mexico plane shows heavy wind and hail
during takeoff Tuesday it crashed
moments later all 103 people aboard
survived Aeromexico flight 24 31 was
traveling from Durango state to Mexico
City at least 65 Americans were on board
the plane Manuel Bojorquez is following
this amazing story Manuel good morning
good morning many of those US citizens
are back home this morning including a
mother we heard from who described
freeing her daughter from the seat and
then dragging her out of the airplane
she told reporters she was holding on to
her so tight she was afraid she might
break her arm it was an emotional
reunion at Chicago's O'Hare
International Airport last night as
family and friends welcomed home Durell
Rivera and her 14 year old daughter
survivors of Tuesday's terrifying crash
we didn't think we were gonna make it I
honestly have no idea how anyone
survived cell phone videos from inside
the aircraft show the plane struggling
in harsh weather conditions moments
before the crash
time-lapse video shows the storm moving
over durango around the time the plane
took off as we started going off the
wind started picking up and then the
hail started coming down on us that the
plane couldn't handle it and it just
came down the Embraer 190 jetliner began
its ascent from the runway but crashed
less than a minute later as a left wing
hit the ground the plane lost both
engines and came to a stop more than 300
yards from the runway as passengers
escaped through the wreckage many fought
through plumes of thick smoke visible
from miles away some survivors like
remain Parsa wonder why the plane took
off at all I think it was a mistake away
the penalty should not have taken off
that's going to be a key question should
that airplane have been allowed to take
off travel industry analysts Henry Hart
uh veldt says while the cruise action
certainly saved lives investigators will
be analyzing the moments leading up to
takeoff pilots have the right by the way
to say I don't think it's safe I'm not
taking off until I'm convinced it's as
safe as it needs to be Aeromexico says
so far 64 passengers have been released
from the hospital Mexican investigators
say they have recovered both at the
airplanes black boxes the National
Transportation Safety Board has sent to
investigators to Mexico to assist their
Ministry of Transportation Alex
Manny thanks a lot of questions still
the answer